in a world where men could get pregnant
in the opening scene we are introduced
to Dr Alex Hess an Austrian research
geneticist and his colleague Dr Larry
Arbogast who is a gynecologist together
they have created a fertility drug
called expectane with the aim of
reducing the chances of miscarriage they
have even tested the drug on a
chimpanzee who has successfully become
pregnant for seven months excited by
their breakthrough in science the duo
presents their research to the Food and
Drug Administration or the FDA and
anxiously awaits their decision a week
later Larry's ex-wife Angela pays him an
unexpected visit to reveal that she is
pregnant but not with his child while
initially Overjoyed Larry's happiness is
short-lived as Angela requests him to be
her doctor so he promptly declines
asking her to find another physician
shortly after Larry receives a call from
the head of the FDA review board named
Noah Baynes who informs him that their
drug has been disapproved that's not all
the FDA has decided to replace their
project object with the one of Dr Diana
Reddin from the ovum cryogenics
Department this turn of events leaves
Alex devastated as he had put their
heart and soul into the research in the
wake of the fda's rejection of their
groundbreaking fertility drug expectane
Dr Alex Hess is considering starting
Anew in Europe however his colleague Dr
Larry Arbogast comes up with a risky but
compelling idea Canadian firm Linden
pharmaceutical is offered to fund their
research provided that they find a
volunteer despite the Drug's unapproved
status Larry believes that they are onto
something big and suggests that they
carry out the experiment secretly
without the fda's knowledge Alex
mentions that no woman would agree to
try out the unapproved drug but Larry
has a solution He suggests omitting the
volunteer's gender and tries to convince
Alex to impregnate himself at first the
latter promptly refuses to do so but he
eventually agrees after giving it some
thought I would mind a baby to proceed
with their experiment however they need
an egg for fertilization hence Larry in
a daring move sneaks into Dr Diana's lab
and steals an ovum labeled junior he
then carries at the process and inserts
the fertilized cell into Alex's body
that night Alex has a vivid dream in
which his potential Offspring has his
own face he wakes up startled and finds
himself at Larry's house later that day
Larry carries out a urine test and
concludes that Alex is now pregnant with
their experiments success as the weeks
go by Dr Diana continues her work in the
lab while Alex experiences a sudden
onset of strange symptoms he rushes to
the bathroom to vomit and complains of
sore nipples to his colleague they feel
so funny Alex also talks incessantly
about walks massages and naps leaving
Larry perplexed Diana who is curious
about Alex's Behavior confronts him and
asks if he is consuming any kind of
drugs Alex vehemently denies it and to
cover up their research Larry comes up
with a story about a random illness that
causes patients to become fat with time
that night Alex can't shake off the
feeling of being pregnant he reads books
about pregnancy and looks at himself in
the mirror as days pass by the Drug's
effects on him become more apparent and
he slowly transforms into a sensitive
person just like pregnant women quite
unlike his true self Alex even breaks
down sobbing after watching TV
commercials and contemplating fatherhood
will you come out my ass where will he
come from will he come out my penis one
day Hilary is preparing to attend a
convention ceremony and Alex also
insists on joining him he says that he
has developed a fear of being left alone
although Larry is initially hesitant he
agrees to take Alex with him when the
latter threatens to stop the experiment
at the convention Larry engages in
discussions with his colleagues about
their research not realizing that the
FDA had Noah is eavesdropping on their
conversation unfortunately Noah becomes
suspicious that the duo is conducting
human experimentation which is a
violation of FDA guidelines he also
notices Alex's unusual behavior which he
finds rather expressive unlike his usual
demeanor in the midst of the party an
overexcited Alex asks Diana for a dance
to which she agrees however neither of
them seems to know how to dance leading
to some awkward and embarrassing moments
on the Dance Floor
after leaving the convention venue Larry
is quick to realize that the
experimental drug has had a significant
impact on Alex's body concerned about
his friend's well-being he urges Alex to
stop taking the drug immediately
explaining that it will lead to the
Natural breakdown and reabsorption of
the embryo despite the fact that the
time has come to end the experiment and
share the results with Linden
pharmaceutical Alex decides to continue
taking the drug and carry the pregnancy
to full term he feels a deep connection
to the child growing inside him and is
determined to nurture it even if it
means undergoing an unnatural process
Larry is frustrated by Alex's decision
knowing that it could have serious
implications for both his physical and
mental health but he also understands
that his friend is no longer thinking
rationally and is completely consumed by
the desire to give birth to the child
with no other option Larry agrees to
help with this unnatural process and
performs a sonographic test to check on
the baby's Health the his relief The
Test shows that the child is growing
normally and appears to be healthy as
Alex's pregnancy progresses he becomes
more and more like a pregnant woman he
experiences all the typical symptoms
including morning sickness sore breasts
and emotional mood swings I'm happy I'm
sad
this impression is terrible in the next
scene Alex can be seen busying himself
in the kitchen preparing a meal while
simultaneously having a conversation
with Larry over the phone he reminds
Larry to be home on time just as a
dutiful wife would in a bid to convey
the intensity of his own experience in
the midst of their conversation Diana
unexpectedly dropped spy to check on
Alex she informs him that she was simply
curious and wanted to see how he was
doing the conversation gradually takes a
romantic turn leading to an intimate
kiss however their moment of passion is
interrupted by the unexpected arrival of
Angela who is also pregnant with her
personal trainer seeing her Diana feels
uneasy and decides to leave after this
Alex has dinner with Angela during which
she comments that he eats like a
pregnant woman he responds with a smile
if only you knew pretending to be
ravenously hungry the following day Alex
and Larry visit a clothing store to
purchase some larger sized outfits for
the pregnant man in the midst of this
shopping spree Alex reveals that he has
decided to name his child Junior this
news surprises Larry as he recalls that
the ovum was also labeled with the same
name and also it's a very stupid name
for a child nevertheless he keeps the
secret of having stolen the ovum from
Diana's laboratory to himself one day
Diana and Alex sit down for dinner
together during their conversation Diana
admits that she has preserved her own
ovum in a container in her lab and she
has named it Junior Alex is taken aback
by this name and excuses himself from
the dinner he immediately confronts
Larry at home and demands that he tell
him the truth Larry finally admits to
stealing the ovum from Diana's lab which
means that the baby he has been carrying
belongs to both Alex and Diana Larry
then blames Alex for continuing to
consume the drug which has led to their
current predicament however Alex becomes
Furious and demands that Larry
apologized to Junior after some
reluctance the latter apologizes to the
baby just then Alex feels the baby kick
and invites Larry to touch his abdomen
unfortunately the beautiful moment is
noticed by Angela who mistakenly assumes
that they are Partners caught in the act
Larry finally reveals the truth about
Alex's pregnancy we gotta blow our own
cover Alex she's gonna think we're gay
causing Angela to collapse out of shock
the very next day Alex heads to die in
his lab to apologize for his behavior
the previous night however on his way he
is spotted by Noah who sees his body
structure and finally realizes that Alex
has conducted the experiments on himself
meanwhile Alex reaches the lab and comes
clean to Diana about everything
including stealing her ovum labeled
Junior from her lab she is initially
taken aback by this Revelation but soon
grows angry feeling that his actions
have undermined the sacred role of
Womanhood and stripped her of her
dignity soon after Noah barges into the
room with two security guards accusing
Alex of continuing the experiment at the
lab's expense he now demands that the
pregnant man turn himself in along with
the baby however Alex is determined to
take control of his own body and refuses
to comply you cannot have my baby in a
fit of rage he pushes Noah against a
table and flees the place outside the
lab Larry pulls up in his car and drives
him away to Safety in order to ensure
Alex's safety from Noah and the
authorities Larry says decides to
disguise himself as a woman and hide him
in a retreat center for expectant
mothers there he claims that Alex's
masculine appearance is due to anabolic
steroid use and the retreat Center's
manager believes him from that day
onwards Alex spends his days practicing
yoga with other future mothers and
learning about baby care amidst this he
also leaves several voice messages for
Diana requesting for a chance to explain
himself after a few days Diana finally
visits Alex at The Retreat he apologizes
to her for everything and tries to
explain the situation Diana responds by
saying that it does not matter who is
pregnant because in the end he is the
father and she is the mother they then
decide to raise the baby together
meanwhile Larry shares the experiment's
data with Linden pharmaceutical and they
agree to partner with him back at the
retreat center Alex experiences severe
abdominal pain so he rushes to his room
to conceal his secret after a while
Diana rushes to The Retreat while Larry
instructs his colleague to prepare for
an emergency C-section unfortunately a
hospital staff overhears their
conversation and alerts Noah who then
immediately summons the media and the
chief of the FDA hoping to take credit
for the world's first pregnant man
however Larry devises a plan to distract
Noah by creating a Decoy for Alex and
enabling a private C-section when Larry
arrives at the hospital the media only
sees the pregnant Angela causing
disappointments among the crowd this
discredits Noah badly causing him to get
fired by the chief immediately while
Larry and Angela enter the hospital
through the main entrance Diana and Alex
use the other way into the building
which is via the fire escape following
this they Rush Alex to the operation
theater and initiate an emergency
C-section cotton European she is coming
Diana is sent to keep Angela company in
the waiting room unaware that the latter
is actually in labor herself when she
finally realizes this Diana is unsure of
what to do but she tries her best to
calm Angela down meanwhile Alex is
successfully able to give birth to a
healthy baby girl oh my God much to the
relief of his friends in the next scene
Larry helps his ex-wife deliver a baby
making everyone erupt in Joy moved by
The Experience he asks for another
chance from Angela and she gladly
accepts they then decide to raise the
baby boy together whom they named Jake
this moment allows them to bond and form
a deeper connection healing the wounds
of their past and looking forward to the
future with their new family the movie
then skips forward one year where we see
that the two families are vacationing
together to celebrate the birthdays of
Junior and Jake we also learned that
Diana is pregnant with her second child
as they all enjoy each other's company
Angela expresses her desire for another
child but admits that she does not want
to endure the physical challenges of
pregnancy again Alex responds to her by
saying that there is another way
implying that Larry can carry the child
for her the movie ends as the group
looks towards Larry who is hesitant and
nervous at the suggestion come on Larry
do it
[__] I'm feeling happy I'm feeling sad
life I feel happy I feel sad subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching